- On this episode, I talk
Snapcash, the Thank You Economy,
and what would I do with
my children on social media
in the future.
Yeah, I know, I said media weird.
Media.
(upbeat music)
You ask questions and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
(upbeat music)
Everybody this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk.
And welcome to episode 44,
thank you,
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Before I get into the questions today,
first of all, I just
want to thank everybody
for the birthday and anniversary wishes.
Had an amazing weekend with Lizzie.
Lizzie, I love you.
Great time off the grid.
Back on the grind.
Ready to close out 2014 with a bang.
The march to 40 years old is on.
And I'm very, very focused.
A couple things: One, if
you're watching this today
on Tuesday, November 18th, what are we?
18th, I will be on the
Seth Meyers show tonight.
So set your DVR or stay up
till 12:05 eastern time.
I don't know what it
is on the other coasts.
Cause the east coast is the best coast.
And two, very interesting
development out of Airbnb.
Nobody asked me this question but I figure
once in a while I want
to rant about things.
Airbnb going into print.
A magazine I think called Pineapple.
I've been a little off the grid..
I gotta answer this Snapcash
question and I haven't
really even played yet, so.
But, a really interesting move to me,
something I want to
address with everybody.
I'm very fond when the
new world goes old world.
I love when Warby Parker€Ž and Birchbox,
an investment of mine, for disclosure,
open up retail stores.
I love when Airbnb makes a print magazine.
CNET making a print magazine.
You know, I'm one who,
you know, kind of like,
pounds on traditional media.
But if the cost structure is
right and the strategy is right
for Airbnb, as they continue
to grow, they're now
trying to get to that final
step which is broad awareness.
And a print magazine in
supermarkets across the country
or Barnes and Nobles is a
way for them to get to that
45 to 75 year old that is not
as savvy, and maybe that cost
of printing on trees
might bring them value.
And so to me I like the
convergence of the new
world going into the old world.
Versus the old world
going into the new world.
- [Voiceover] Tyler asks,
"Do you still think the
Thank You Economy will
self destruct in 2015?
Are brands living up to your
predictions slash Thank You
Economy expectations?"
- Tyler, once again, and I
talk about it all the time,
I think things are gonna
happen sooner than they become.
My prediction in Thank You
Economy was that people
would understand this and
then everybody would do it.
And by 2015, it would get ruined.
I am so off on that prediction
it's borderline embarrassing.
You know, DRock, I don't know,
can you like, take my face
right now and give me like, rosy cheeks?
Like, can you like make
my face red right now?
Because I'm so embarrassed
by how off I am.
Because, two part.
One, people just haven't
adopted the Thank You Economy.
And thus, if they haven't
adopted it and scaled
and ruined it, how can it be over, right?
And so, it might take a lot longer.
It may take forever.
More importantly, the people
that do attack the world
in a TYE world are getting dividends.
I'm getting those emails.
But it has not been the
landslide that I had hoped
for the consumer.
So, my prediction was obnoxiously off.
One, it may not happen,
at scale because companies
are just heartless and
just don't understand the
financial benefit.
And listen, I'm heartless.
I mean it's all about the wallet with TYE.
I mean to me, it's, this
is how you do business.
And two, it's not enough at
enough scale or ruined yet.
People are still flabbergasted
and excited when a
business acknowledges
them or does something
half-assed caring.
- Hey Gary, this is
Kyle @JockNerd and Ruby.
She's two and a half.
And I was wondering in the
future, how are you going to
treat social media with your children?
Oh no, don't hide.
Say hi.
Can you wave?
- Oh, cute.
- Hi.
- Hey.
Kyle, Ruby, you know
it's been interesting.
Lizzie and I, look it's hard
to find pictures of Lizzie
on the internet.
Let alone, you know, all full blast.
And Misha and Xander are even more of a
rare commodity.
I'm not sure.
I mean, obviously, I have a
partner in crime in this answer.
Lizzie, is very much the
CEO of the household.
I'd like to think I'm the COO.
Sometimes I'm just like, you
know, the maintenance man.
No, I mean, the truth is, we
communicate a lot about this.
You know, I'm a counter puncher.
I talk a lot about that.
I react to the time.
For me to predict where
social is gonna be or
the technology.
But what I do know is one thing.
It's amazing to watch 13
year old girl behavior
where their spending 45
minutes on the lighting
and the angle on a Instagram photo.
And then if it doesn't get
enough likes in the first
three minutes, they take it down.
So clearly self esteem is very
wrapped up in these things.
And every parent loves
their child so much that you
want to keep them away
from bullying and being
made fun of or getting into
things too early in their lives.
I have the extra pressure,
in my opinion, of deciding to
raise my children in
Manhattan where an 8 year old
maps more like a 17 year old in many other
parts of the country.
And so, it's a challenge.
And it's something that
I think a lot about.
And something I care a lot about.
I'm not sure exactly how
we're going to handle it.
I think we're going to
handle it by instilling an
enormous amount of love into our children.
It's very important to us
to establish a foundation of
who they are.
We've been spending a lot of time of like,
mission statements, and
like key pillars that we
want to instill of how we
want them to act, how we
want them to treat others
is very important to me.
Imposing enormous self esteem into them is
important to me.
And I think that to me,
there's new dynamics, but
it's still always the same
and what I mean by that is
the core pillars of good
parenting haven't changed
since the beginning of time.
There's new dynamics.
Those things are probably
more important than ever.
Having more self esteem,
more perseverance,
better manners, all those
things probably matter
more than ever.
And so, I'm gonna just try
to deliver tried and true
things to my kids, much
like I do with business.
The world changes, but the
principles of patience,
and believing your
people, and establishing
infrastructure and playing the long game.
I've said it before in this show,
you know, a tortoise in a
hare's costume, you know,
I believe in old school things like that.
So I'm just gonna instill
really good, core fundamentals
and let the outside world evolve
because I can't control it.
And just instill my
children into that world,
most prepared and best
positioned to succeed.
- [Voiceover] Everybody
asks, "What do you think
about SnapCash?"
- Alright, I get it.
You want to know about SnapCash.
I just watched the video.
Nice job, nice production.
Look, I think this continues.
This is why I invested
in Venmo four years ago.
The thought of payment
transfers amongst people in a
paperless, cashless
world is very important.
And to layer it into a social
network, what I like about it
for SnapChat is they're
getting in very early.
What I mean by very early
is not into the game,
very early in one's age
to create the behavior.
Because SnapChat has a heavy
13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19
year old demo, they can
capture a lot of that behavior.
I always thought that Facebook,
I remember thinking that
the social network I wanted
to build when Facebook was
blowing it up was one that
was around your license.
Because I wanted to get the people
before they went to college.
And I thought like, if we
start a social network where
your license was your
gateway in, that there was
something there and that's
what SnapChat has done.
It's gone earlier.
It creates behavior.
Look, cryptocurrency, Apple
Pay, this kind of stuff with
Square and SnapChat, if I'm a
traditional financial service,
I'm very concerned about
the enormous innovation over
the last 24 months invading on my turf.
And if I'm a consumer, I'm extremely happy
because competition breeds
enormous innovation.
And the number one thing we love is time.
And I see a lot of things
in the financial world
saving us time now.
Saving us time to go into
our wallet and take this out,
and take out cash.
Ooh, I actually have to
give a receipts to Matt.
You know, so that's good.
And you know, or this,
taking out a credit card
and swiping it takes time.
All these things are much
quicker in this world.
Speed, my friends.
In sports and in business
really matters cause we
value time the most.
Might be time to get a watch.
Question of the day.
What is your number one
most recent app download.
What is the last app you
downloaded on your phone?
I'm gonna give you my answer.
I'm not quite sure.
I think, hold on, I want
to give you the truth.
Hold on, I'm screwing up the show.
I know there was
something very very recent
that I liked.
I'm playing with Swipe.
Swipe is fairly recent for me.
Let me show it one more time.
Swipe right there.
So, S-W-I-P-E.
Check that out.
Thanks for watching 44.
Little chill, kind of like
post vacation intensity.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Check out Seth Meyers tonight
and subscribe to the show.
Don't forget the podcast.
Oh crap, wait, subscribe.
I need subscriptions because
I can't push this many
right hooks in social.
So, subscribe.